this started out as a short that Gillian
made with Jenny right in what year was
that when we shot the short in 2009 four
in four days with no money I was sitting
in the editing room with my editor and
we had a rough cut of 30 minutes and it
was amazing
Jenny's performance just blew me away
you know we didn't watch dailies because
it was a short and I you know wasn't
fine-tuned director yet and I was
watching all the footage putting it
together
and the performance just was so stunning
and the way Jenny as Donna navigated
between a range of like guttural laughs
and heartbreaking moments I just knew
this needed to be told in a bigger way
because of the performance and also I
wanted the story to be told in a bigger
way but we didn't have the money and we
didn't have the story yet and we all had
to go off and be grownups and and our
careers had to you know mature and Jenny
moved to LA and I stayed in New York and
I met Elizabeth at a mixer I had a IFP
which is like a great program because it
brought Elizabeth and I together and
that's sort of where the the feature was
was born I had an early draft of the
script and I was looking to find a
partner to help me get this made and Liz
was that partner the development process
was really just working on the script
for a long time figuring out Donna's
character turning her into a stand-up
comedian getting to know her family her
friends her world trying to find
conflict when we never wanted the
conflict to be will she or won't she go
through with the abortion you know it's
a complex emotional experience but it's
we don't want that to be the question we
always knew it would be you know a
decisive moment for her and so it was
really about will she or won't she have
the courage to let someone in to connect
to someone to be honest with herself and
with him it's really developing that the
relationship with Max and looking to
some of our favorite romantic comedies
of all time and and really using those
tropes but kind of infusing it with this
modern twist
and so yeah we financing was sort of the
most boring part of what I do but like a
mix of equity and grants and Kickstarter
and the tax credit and you name it we
did it and it actually didn't take very
long at all I think we found the right
partners who were really eager to make
this happen and to be part of this crazy
family and and then we shot for 18 days
in Brooklyn and Manhattan didn't like my
boyfriend's apartment our friend's
apartments with the support of Planned
Parenthood we shot in a Planned
Parenthood didn't in Westchester and
yeah we were in post sort of all summer
and fall Gillian and I both were working
day jobs I used to run the phone program
for Kickstarter for three years and
Gillian was at the Directors Guild of
America and we took some time off for
prep and production but other than that
we were just totally ruining our
boyfriend's lives and being workaholics
do you anticipate the conversation about
it changing in any way when it starts to
open in redder States and it's opened in
so far probably that makes sense to me I
think what we can do is to keep our
voice steady and keep moving in one
direction which is of course we are
pro-choice and want to be part of a
movement that you know helps everybody
make choice that's right for them and
secures those rights but I I've been
thinking about this a lot because in
general I'm very uncomfortable with
confrontation
I don't get in a lot of arguments with
my friends my parents when I have fights
with my husband
they really bum me out for like a long
long time I recently heard that if you
heard a pig's feelings that it will have
hurt feelings for like two weeks and but
I can't avoid it you know we made this
movie and I stand by it and as we as the
script was being developed and I started
to think more and more about it and
watch what was going on in our country
found myself really wanting to have a
voice in in the I hate
call it a fight but it is it it's a
struggle but it seems like there's one
side that it seems like there are like
some rules laid down about how we should
fight this fight and I just reject that
because I I think you can say things and
do things in a way that is earnest but
also strong and doesn't have to be
bitter and you know like the second you
see someone's fiscal up you punch them
in the face and when when we were in
Dallas there was a woman that stood up
at the end of the very very positive and
you know really fervent Q&A that was you
know really excited about the film and
she was upset about the way that one of
the jokes went down in the movie and she
asked a question about it you know I
don't agree with her opinion at all but
the crowd was sort of really against her
and that honestly made me more
uncomfortable than her disagreeing with
us was just the inability to have a like
a conversation where people just have
good behavior and so I think for us we
were really thoughtful about this film I
know sometimes we step over the line but
I think that what makes something modern
is when it it's flexible with boundaries
that you know I think like you see that
in general in like literature you know
like it and I think it's important for
us to say we are a thoughtful playful
strong voice and you shouldn't
underestimate us but you should also
engage and we're here for a proper
useful conversation